scarlet johansson reveals she's ready to
say goodbye to black widow we have
unfinished business as fans get a sneak
peek at the new movie what are we going
to get out of the new movie closure I
don't know if I could take it anymore
without any closure it's too exhausting
yeah I love it I'm so proud of what we
made the origin story marked scar Joe's
ninth time playing the title character
meanwhile David Harbor makes his Marvel
Universe debut as the Soviet version of
Captain America family back together
again
you gotta fit alexei yeah it's a
tremendously flawed guy
from one superhero to another army
hammers Batman confession didn't you
almost get the role of Batman I did get
the role at Batman and then there was
like a confluence of elements that
really yeah made the movie stop and it
was like really heartbreaking 19 year
old army was set to start production on
Justice League mortal in 2005 when
studio heads reportedly decided to pull
the plug because they didn't want his
movie to go up against Christian Bale's
Dark Knight's
so no Batcave but now Army's diving deep
into SC cave on running wild with Bear
Grylls
he's one of 10 celebs looking for
adventure this season this season we
just had Channing Tatum for the second
time many of these cells wanting that
kind of pride and confidence that the
wild delivers army also comes clean on
how he finally got his big break in this
social network there so they're like we
need to survive guy you're six foot five
you do it
[Music]